We're talking Super Bowl Sunday with dynamic duo,
Cari Champion and Jemele Hill.
Yes, hi.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
All right, guys.
Rossi, what's next?
All right, well, this is the first time in almost 20 years
that the Super Bowl has not been held on the first Sunday
of the month, and the Independent reports,
bot everybody is happy with new date
because it crashes right into
Valentine's day weekend, right?
And TikTok wants to know who is responsible for this.
And they think definitely someone who is single,
who definitely does not have a Valentine to spend it with.
Like you and me, Cari.
Correct.
I didn't do the math really, that it's Sunday the 13th
is Super Bowl, next day is Valentine's day.
People are probably gonna be hung over,
not their best version of themselves for Valentine's day.
And yet, I feel like I've been invited,
for the first time in what seems like years, 'cause it is,
I've been invited to some Valentine's day parties that are
happening on Saturday night,
so I feel like it's like Halloween, people are getting their
Valentine's day on over the weekend.
Valentine's day party?
So I'm like, "What are people complaining about?"
You got Saturday night, Sunday football
and Monday Valentine's day.
What is the problem?
(Ross laughs)
But Cari, Jemele, thoughts?
Over Valentine's day.
And I just feel like, here comes grumpy Cari.
I feel like everyone, it's a made up holiday,
especially when you're single, and for single people,
it really is just another reminder, if you're not
in a good space, that you ain't got no man or no woman.
So therefore, I'm all about the football,
unlike my bestie Jemele here, who's like,
"I'm taking my husband, we're in love."
(Drew laughs)
That's cute.
Jemele, thoughts, feelings, Valentine's day Super Bowl,
what's it all about?
So, this to me is the perfect time to wage my campaign.
And I always feel like, any politician that's running
for office, if you want to unite the entire country,
we need to push for the day after Super Bowl
to be a national holiday, that everybody gets a day off,
because if that were the case, then it would allow us
to recalibrate and perhaps celebrate Valentine's day
if you choose to do that that night.
I also think, I think you could sort of make
this weekend part of the Valentine's day thing.
So it's not, not just one day to celebrate,
maybe you could score a touchdown all weekend long
if you know what I mean.
I mean, there's, you could score, score, score.
Yay.
(all laughing)
All right, well next up, we have got a heart warmer
about the Bengals.
There is a diehard fan, his name is James Lipscomb.
He's 86 years old and he has been a fan for over 50 years.
He was at the very first Bengal game ever in 1968,
and now he just went virtual for his reaction
when they beat the chiefs to make it to the Super Bowl.
Watch this.
(indistinct chatter on TV)
How happy are you, dad?
Oh my God.
And now, People report that thanks to a GoFundMe campaign
started in his family, James, AKA the Cincinnati Grandpa
is headed to the Super Bowl.
Yes!
And that's the kinda rallying I love to see.
I mean, that is just the most heartwarming story.
Thank you, People, for bringing that to people's attention,
and now he and his whole family are gonna go,
they raised like $40,000.
They're gonna give him tickets, a hotel room, great seats.
Come on.
This is, this is this.
(applause)
This gets me, you know?
Well, Cari and Jemele, I just love getting to do this
with you, you truly are authorities,
you're incredible people.
Check out their podcast, Naked with Cari Champion,
and Jemele Hill is Unbothered,
and see them together on CNN+.
The show Speak.Easy.
(upbeat music)